الله
[Silence]
‏an
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الص
الصلا حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله سووا
اعتدلوا سووا الصفوف ست الفرج ريت لاين
كبس الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
[Silence]
امين
الم را تلك ايات الكتاب وقران
مبين ربما يود الذين كفروا لو كانوا
مسلمين
ذرهم ياكلوا ويتمتعوا ويلههم الامل فسوف
يعلمون وما اهلكنا من قريه الا ولها كتاب
معلوم ما تسبق من اممه اجلها وما
يستاخرون وقالوا يا ايها الذي نزل عليه
الذكر انك
لمجنون لو ما تاتي
بالملائكه ان كنت من
الصادقين ما ننزل الملائكه الا بالحق وما
كانوا اذا
منظرين انا نحن نزلنا الذكر وانا له
لحافظون الله ا
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عل
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد ارسلنا من قبلك في شيع
الاولين وما ياتيهم من رسول الا كانوا به
يستهزئون كذلك نسلكه في قلوب
المجرمين لا يؤمنون به وقد خلت سنه
الاولين ولو فتحنا عليهم بابا من السماء
فظلوا فيه
يعرجون لقالوا انما سكرت ابصارنا بل نحن
قوم مسحورون
ولقد جعلنا في السماء بروجا وزيناها
للناظرين وحفظناها من كل شيطان رجيم الا
من استرق السمع فاتبعه شهاب
مبين والارض مددناها والقينا فيها رواسي
وانبتنا فيها وانبتنا فيها من كل شيء
موزون
وجعلنا لكم فيها معايش ومن لستم له
برازقين وان من شيء الا عندنا
خزائنه وما ننزله الا بقدر
معلوم وارسلنا الرياح لواقح فانزلنا من
السماء
ماء فاسقيناكموه
وما انتم له
بخازنين وانا لنحن نحيي ونميت ونحن
الوارثون ولقد علمنا المستقدمين منكم ولقد
علمنا المستا
اخرين وان ربك هو
يحشرهم انه حكيم
عليم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السكم ull
‏any just take about
what more what the
cuse
that teach
[Silence]
‏and 71
and
that know think close
to
sch
sch what
have
now that scho set it requires l of
teachers so we have at ‏i believe there
are about 12 sta mers on on our
p and the reason i'm mention i me these
things up and that's where we our cost
is incur right we are not paying any r
we not paying any utility separately but
we are paying for the tu for the teacher
serves that are that we need and that is
something that is know
sign ex
85%
small
number 85%
‏and have
15%
don now that 15% part of that
tr so now let about what going be asking
ises people from all of you what you can
make 100 mon
00 let me just ref
so
just
man small
[Silence]
‏careful
take
2500 make
‏have all
same you think you want sp the money and
that you can always do that those who
feel payment we work you so without
any more disc on this thing
just see you tomorrow at j one last
thing that i would say is when we are
asking for this thing j ask at minut of
your time as a donation just think about
this you giving that
‏and s st
and other what take care so that don
people any
minut comm
لام
[Silence]
استووا استووا
اعتدلوا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العال العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ولقد خلقنا الانسان من صلصال من حماء
مسنون
والجان خلقناه من قبل من نار
السموم واذ قال ربك
للملائكه اني خالق بشرا من صلصال من حما
مسنون فاذا سويته ونفخت فيه من روحي فقعوا
له
ساجدين فسجد الملائكه كلهم
اجمعون الا ابليس ابى ان يكون مع
الساجدين قال يا ابليس ما لك الا تكون مع
الساجدين قال لم اكن لاسجد لبشر خلقته من
صلصال من حما
مسنون قال خرج منها فانك رجيم وان عليك
اللعنه الى يوم الدين قال رب فانظرني الى
يوم
يبعثون قال فانك من
المنظرين الى يوم الوقت
المعلوم قال رب بما اغويتني لاقع قال رب
بما اغويتني
لازينن لهم في الارض ولاغي ينهم
اجمعين الا عبادك منهم
المخلصين قال ف قال هذا صراط علي مستقيم
ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم سلطان الا من اتبعك
من
الغاوين وان جهنم لموعد
اجمعين وان جهنم لموعدهم
اجمعين لها سبعه ابواب لكل باب منهم جزء
مقسوم ان المتقين في جنات
وعيون ادخلوها بسلام امنين ونزعنا ما في
صدورهم من غل اخوانا على سرر
متقابلين لا يمسهم فيها نصب وما هم منها
بمخرجين
نبئ عبادي اني انا الغفور الرحيم وان
عذابي هو العذاب الاليم ونبئهم عن ضيف
ابراهيم اذ دخلوا عليه فقالوا سلاما قال
انا منكم
وجلون قالوا لا توجل انا نبشرك بغلام عليم
قال
على ان مسني الكبر فبم
تبشرون قالوا بشرناك بالحق فلا تكن من
القانطين قال ومن يقنط من رحمه ربه الا
الضالون قال فما خطبكم ايها
المرسلون قالوا انا ارسلنا الى قوم مجرمين
الا ال لوط انا لمنجوهم
اجمعين الا امراته قدرنا انها لمن
الغابرين فلما جاء ال لوط لل المرسلون قال
انكم قوم
منكرون قالوا بل جئناك بما كانوا فيه
يمترون واتيناك بالحق وانا
لصادقون فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل واتبع
ادبارهم ولا يلتفت منكم احد وامضوا حيث
تؤمرون وقضينا اليه ذلك الامر ان دابر
هؤلاء مقطوع
مصبحين وجاء اهل المدينه
يستبشرون قال ان
هؤلاء ضيفي فلا
تفضحون واتقوا الله ولا
تخزون قالوا اولم ننهك عن
العالمين قال
هؤلاء بناتي ان كنتم
فاعلين لعمرك انهم لفي سكرتهم
يعمهون فاخذتهم الصيحه مشرقين فجعلنا ليها
سافلها وامطرنا عليها حجاره من
سجيل ان في ذلك لايات للمتوسمين
وانها لبسبيل
مقيم ان في ذلك لايه
للمؤمنين وان كان اصحاب الايكه
لظالمين
فانتقمنا منهم وانهما لب بامام مبين ولقد
كذب اصحاب الحجر المرسلين واتيناهم اياتنا
فكانوا عنها
معرضين وكانوا ينحتون من الجبال بيوتا
امنين فاخذتهم الصيحه
مصبحين فما اغنى عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا
بالحق وان الساعه
لاتيه فاصفح الصفح
الجميل الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا بالحق وان الساعه لاتيه فاصفح
الصفح
الجميل ان ربك هو الخللا
العليم ولقد اتيناك سبعا من المثاني
والقران
العظيم لا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به
ازواجا منهم ولا تحزن عليهم واخفض جناحك
للمؤمنين وقل اني انا النذير
المبين كما انزلنا على المق
مسمين الذين جعلوا القران
عضين فوربك
لنسالنهم
اجمعين عما كانوا يعملون فاصدع بما تؤمر
واعرض عن
المشركين انا كفيناك
المستهزئين الذين يجعلون مع الله الها اخر
فسوف يعلمون
ولقد نعلم انك يضيق صدرك بما
يقولون فسبح بحمد ربك وكن من
الساجدين واعبد ربك حتى ياتيك
اليقين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اتى امر الله فلا
تستعجلوه سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون ينزل
الملائكه بالروح من امره على من يشاء من
عباده ان
انذروا ان انذروا انه لا اله الا انا
فاتقون خلق السماوات والارض بالحق تعالى
عما
يشركون خلق الانسان من نطفه فاذا هو خصي
مبين والانعام
خلقها لكم فيها دفء ومنافع ومنها
تاكلون ولكم فيها جمال حين تريحون وحين
تسرحون وتحمل اثقالكم الى بلد لم تكونوا
بالغيه الا بشق
الانفس ان ربكم لرؤوف رحيم
والخيل والبغال والحمير لتركبوها
وزينه ويخلق ما لا
تعلمون وعلى الله قصد السبيل ومنها
جائر ولو شاء لهداكم
اجمعين هو الذي انزل من السماء ماء لكم
منه شراب ومنه شجر فيه تسي
ينبت لكم به الزرع والزيتون والنخيل
والاعناب ومن كل الثمرات
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يتفكرون وسخر لكم الليل والنهار والشمس
والقمر
والنجوم
مسخرات
بامره ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون وما ذرا لكم في الارض مختلفا
الوانه ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يذكرون وهو الذي سخر البحر لتاكلوا منه
لحما طريا وتستخرجوا منه حليه
تلبسونها وترى الفلك مواخر فيه ول ابتغوا
من فضله ولعلكم
تشكرون والقى في الارض رواسي ان تميد بكم
وانهارا وسبلا لعلكم
تهتدون
وعلامات وبالنجم هم
يهتدون افمن يخلق كمن لا يخلق افلا
تذكرون وان تعدوا نعمه الله
تحصوها ان الله لغفور
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
‏m
[Silence]
ان شاء الله
ركعه سجده
تلاوه ركج
تلاو
سجود قيام ان شاء
الله الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغ ضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والله يعلم ما تسرون وما
تعلنون والذين يدعون من دون الله لا
يخلقون شيئا وهم يخلقون
اموات غير
احياء وما يشعرون ايان
يبعثون الهكم اله واحد فالذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره قلوبهم منكره وهم
مستكبرون لا جرم ان الله يعلم ما يسرون
وما يعلنون انه لا يحب المستكبرين
واذا قيل لهم ماذا انزل ربكم قالوا اساطير
الاولين ليحملوا اوزارهم كامله يوم
القيامه ومن اوزار الذين
يضلونهم بغير علم الا ساء ما
يزرون قد مكر الذين من قبلهم فاتى الله
بنيان هم من القواعد فخر عليهم السقف من
فوقهم واتاهم
العذاب واتاهم العذاب من حيث لا
يشعرون ثم يوم القيامه يخزيهم ويقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم
تشاقون فيهم قال الذين اوتوا العلم ان
الخزي يوم والسوء على
الكافرين الذين تتوفاهم الملائكه ظالمي
انفسهم فالقوا السلم ما كنا نعمل من
سوء بلى ان الله عليم بما كنتم
تعملون فادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها
فلبئس مثوى المتكبرين
وقيل للذين اتقوا ماذا انزل ربكم قالوا
خيرا للذين احسنوا في هذه الدنيا
حسنه ولدار الاخره خير ولنعم دار
المتقين جنات عدن يدخلونها تجري من تحتها
الانهار لهم فيها ما يشاءون
كذلك يجزي الله
المتقين الذين تتوفاهم
الملائكه طيبين يقولون سلام
عليكم طبتم فادخلوها
خالدين الذين تتوفاهم الملائكه طيبين
يقولون سلام عليكم ادخلوا الجنه بما كنتم
تعملون هل ينظرون الا ان تاتيهم الملائكه
او ياتي امر ربك كذلك فعل الذين من
قبلهم وما ظلمهم الله ولكن كانوا انفسهم
يظلمون فاصابهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم
ما كانوا به
يستهزئون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وقال الذين اشركوا لو شاء الله ما عبدنا
من دونه من شيء نحن ولا
اباؤنا ولا حرمنا من دونه من
شيء كذلك فعل الذين من قبل لهم فهل على
الرسل الا البلاغ
المبين ولقد بعثنا في كل امه رسولا ان
اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا
الطاغوت فمنهم من هدى الله ومنهم من حقت
عليه الضلاله فسيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف
كان عاقبه
المكذبين ان تحرص على هداهم فان ان الله
لا يهدي من
يضل وما لهم من
ناصرين واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لا يبعث
الله من يموت بلى وعدا عليه حقا ولكن اكثر
الناس لا
يعلمون ليبين لهم الذي يختلفون فيه وليعلم
الذين كفروا انهم كانوا
كاذبين انما قولنا لشيء اذا اردناه ان
نقول له كن
فيكون والذين هاجروا في الله من بعد ما
ظلموا لنبوئنهم في الدنيا حسنه ولاجر
الاخره اكبر لو كانوا
يعلمون الذين صبروا وعلى ربهم يتوكل
وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا رجالا نوحي اليهم
فاسالوا اهل الذكر ان كنتم لا
تعلمون بالبينات
والزبر وانزلنا اليك الذكر لتبين للناس ما
نزل اليهم ولعلهم
يتفكرون افامن الذين مكروا السيئات ان
يخسف الله بهم الارض او ياتيهم العذاب من
حيث لا
يشعرون او ياخذهم في تقلبهم فما هم
بمعجزين او ياخذهم على تخوف فان ربكم
لرؤوف
رحيم اولم يروا الى ما خلق الله من شيء
يتفيا ظلاله عن اليمين
والشمائل سجدا لله وهم
داخرون ولله يسجد ما في السماوات وما في
الارض من
دابه
والملائكه وهم لا
يستكبرون يخافون ربهم من فوقهم ويفعلون ما
يؤمرون
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله و
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ون و ومن
تبع باحسان الى يوم الدين بعد شاء الله
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
حث تبسمك في وجه اخيك
صدقه
that
sister s
[Silence]
السلام علكم ورحمه الله
و السلام عل
السلام عل و السلام ورحمه الله
وبكاته peace and
kindness posi at home spes
parents i think
iou i and think most of us
are
‏friendes
weing
and
ch
very
spes
and عليه الصه والسلام ‏you know say this
and fl from
say all one
wife
exem
after
was
house
would from
[Silence]
ح
‏mind years ag years ag i man who used
to work
a5 in
w so he would commute to wet and go back
subur to house and he a young child and
the young child was init of as soon as
par the car in the garage
the hand
‏food paint whatever
soad you know st him coule of times bad
so he said he put usain coat in his
garage so as soon as par the car he put
onat and walk in the house and the kid
hug him with dirty hands that was never
a and this is not
a you know read the st years ag probably
even i don't know 15 20 years ago
somewhere you know was a practical story
that
[Silence]
‏and make
سالول الحق لا اله الا الله محمد رسول
الله ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر
وكنا عذاب جنم وكنا شر فتنه المحت وكنا
شرته المسيح الجال ربنا تقبل منم عليم وتب
علينا وك تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم
الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين جزاك
[Silence]
الله استقيم اعتدل استو سو الصب سد الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستع
عين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال الله لا تتخذوا الهين اثنين
انما هو اله واحد
فاياي فارهبون
وله ما في السماوات والارض وله الدين
واصبا افغير الله
تتقون وما بكم من نعمه فمن
الله ثم اذا مسكم الضر فاليه
تجارون ثم اذا كشف الضر عنكم اذا فريق
منكم بربهم
يشركون ليكفروا بما اتيناهم فتمتعوا فسوف
تعلمون ويجعلون لما لا يعلمون نصيبا مما
رزقناهم ت الله
لتسالن عما كنتم
تفترون ويجعل لون لله البنات سبحانه ولهم
ما
يشتهون واذا بشر احدهم بالانثى ظل وجهه
مسودا وهو كظيم يتوارى من القوم من
سوء ما بشر به ايمسكه على هون ام يدسه في
التراب
الا
ساء ما
يحكمون للذين لا يؤمنون في بالاخره مثل
السوء ولله المثل الاعلى وهو العزيز
الحكيم ولو يؤاخذ الله الناس بظلمهم ما
ترك عليها من دابه
ولكن يؤخرهم الى اجل
مسمى فاذا جاء اجلهم لا يستاخرون
ساعه ولا
يستقدمون ويجعلون لله ويصفون
لله ويجعلون لله ما يكرهون وتصف السنتهم
الكذبه بان لهم
الحسنى الا جرم ان لهم النار
وانهم
مفرطون ت الله لقد
ارسلنا ت الله لقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك
فزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فهو
وليهم فهو وليهم اليوم ولهم عذاب اليم وما
انزلنا عليك الكتاب
الا الا لتبين لهم الذي اختلفوا فيه وهدى
ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون والله
انزل من
السماء ماء
والله انزل من
السماء
ماء فاحيا به الارض بعد
موتها ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يسمعون
وان لكم في الانعام
لعبره
نسقيكم مما في
بطونه من بين فرث ودم
لبنا لبنا
خالصا
سائغا
للشاربين ومن ثمرات النخيل
والاعناب ومن ثمرات النخيل والاعناب
تتخذون منه
رزقا و تتخذون منه سكرا ورزقا
حسنا ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يعقلون واوحى ربك الى النحل ان اتخذي من
الجبال
بيوتا ان اتخذي من الجبال بيوتا ومن الشجر
ومما
يعرشون ثم كلي من كل ل الثمرات
فاسلكي سبل ربك
ذللا يخرج من بطونها شراب مختلف
الوانه فيه
شفاء
للناس والله
اخرجكم ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يتفكرون والله خلقكم ثم
يتوفاكم
ومنكم من يرد الى ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم
بعد علم شيئا ان الله عليم
قدير والله فضل بعضكم على بعض في الرزق
فما الذين فضلوا
برادي رزقهم على ما ملكت ايمانهم فهم فهم
فيه
سواء اف بنعمه الله
يجحدون والله جعل لكم من
انفسكم
ازواجا وجعل لكم من
ازواجكم بنين وحفده ورزقكم من
الطيبات افبالباطل
يؤمنون وبنعمه الله هم
يكفرون
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا يملك لهم
رزقا ما لا يملك لهم رزقا من السماوات
والارض
ما لا يملك لهم رزقا من السماوات والارض
شيئا ولا
يستطيعون فلا تضربوا لله
الامثال ان الله يعلم
وانتم لا
تعلمون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ضرب الله مثلا عبدا مملوكا لا يقدر
على شيء ومن
رزقناه ومن رزقناه من رزقا حسنا فهو ينفق
منه سرا
وجهرا هل
يستوون الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا يعلمون
وضرب الله مثل الرجلين احدهما ابكم لا
يقدر على شيء وهو كل على
مولاه وهو كل على مولاه اينما يوجهه لا
ياتي
بخير هل يستوي هو ومن يامر بالعدل وهو على
صراط
مستقيم ولله غيب السماوات والارض وما امر
الساعه الا كلمح البصر او هو اقرب ان
الله ان الله على كل شيء ق قدير والله
اخرجكم من بطون
امهاتكم لا تعلمون شيئا وجعل لكم السمع
والابصار والافئده قليلا ما
تشكرون وجعل لكم السمع والابصار والافئده
لعلكم
تشكرون الم يروا الى الطير مسخرا
في جو
السماء ما
يمسكهن الا الله
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون والله جعل لكم من بيوتكم
سكنا وجعل لكم من جلود الانعام بيوتا
تستخفونها يوم ظعنكم ويوم
اقامتكم ومن اصوافها واوبارها
واشعارها اثاثا ومتاعا الى حين والله جعل
لكم مما خلق
ظلالا وجعل لكم من الجبال
اكنانا وجعل لكم سرابيل تقيكم الحر و
رابيل
تقيكم
باسكم كذلك يتم نعمته عليكم لعلكم
تسلمون فان تولوا فانما عليك البلاغ
المبين يعرفون نعمه الله ثم
ينكرونها واكثرهم
الكافرون ويوم يبعث في كل
امه
شهيدا
ثم لا يؤذن للذين كفروا ولا هم
يستعتبون واذا راى الذين ظلموا العذاب فلا
يخفف عنهم ولا هم
ينظرون واذا راى الذين اشركوا
شركاءهم قالوا ربنا
قالوا ربنا
هؤلاء
شركاؤنا الذين كنا ندعو من دونك فالقوا
اليهم القول انكم
لكاذبون والقوا الى الله يومئذ السلم وضل
عنهم ما كانوا يفترون
الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله زدناهم
عذابا زدناهم
عذابا فوق العذاب بما كانوا
يفسدون ويوم نبعث من كل امه شهيدا عليهم
من
انفسهم وجئنا بك شهيدا على هؤلا
ونزلنا عليك الكتاب تبيانا لكل
شيء وهدى
ورحمه
وبشرى
للمسلمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم
واعتدل الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء
والمنكر
والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واوفوا بعهد لله اذا عاهدتم ولا
تنقضوا الايمان بعد توكيدها وقد جعلتم
الله عليكم
كفيلا ان الله عليم بما
تفعلون ان الله يعلم ما
تعملون ان الله يعلم ما
تفعلون ولا تكونوا كالتي نقضت غزلها من
بعد قوه انكاثا
تتخذون تتخذون ايمانكم دخلا بينكم ان تكون
امه هي اربى من
امه
انما يبلوكم الله به
وليبين لكم يوم القيامه ما كنتم فيه
تختلفون
تختلفون ولو
شاء الله لجعلكم امه
واحده ولكن يضل من
يشا ويهدي من
يشاء ول تسالون
عما كنتم
تعملون ولا تتخذوا ايمانكم دخلا بينكم
فتزل قدم بعد
ثبوتها وتذوق
السوء بما صددتم عن سبيل الله ولكم عذاب
عظيم ولا تشتروا بعهد الله ثمنا قليلا
انما عند الله هو خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون ما عندكم ينفد وما عند الله
باق
ولنجزين الذين صبروا اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون من عمل
صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو مؤمن
فلنحيينه
حياه طيبه
ولنجزينهم اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون
يعملون فكلوا
مما رزقكم الله حلالا
طيبا فاذا قرئ
القران فاذا قرئ الق فاذا قرات
القران فاذا قرات القران جعلنا فاذا قرات
القران فاذا قرات القران فاستعذ بالله من
من الشيطان الرجيم
انه ليس له سلطان على الذين امنوا وعلى
ربهم
يتوكلون
انما سلطانه على الذين
يتولونه والذين هم به
مشركون واذا بدلنا ايه مكان ايه والله
اعلم بما ينزل قالوا انما انت مفتر بل
اكثرهم لا يعلمون قل نزله روح القدس من
ربك
بالحق ليثبت الذين
امنوا ليثبت الذين امنوا
وهد وبشرى
للمسلمين ولقد نعلم ان هم يقولون انما
يعلمه بشر لسان الذي يلحدون اليه اعجمي
وهذا لسان عربي
مبين ان الذين لا يؤمنون بايات الله لا
يهديهم الله لا يهديهم الله ولهم عذاب
عظيم انما يفتري الكذب الذين لا يؤمنون
بايات
الله
واولئك هم
الكافرون
الكاذبون من كفر بالله من من بعد من كفر
بعد ايمانه
الا من كفر بالله من بعد ايمانه الا من
اكره وقلبه
مطمئن
بالايمان ولكن من شرح بالكفر صدرا فعليهم
غضب من
ربهم فعليهم
الله ولهم عذاب اليم
ذلك
بانه مستحب الحياه الدنيا على الاخره وان
الله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين
اولئك الذين طبع الله على قلوبهم وسمعهم
وابصارهم
واولئك هم الغافلون
لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم
الخاسرون ثم ان ربك للذين هاجروا من بعد
ما
فتنوا
ثم جاهدوا
وصبروا
ان ربك من بعدها لغفور رحيم
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يوم تاتي كل نفس تجادل عن
نفسها وتوفى كل نفس ما عملت وهم لا
يظلمون وضرب الله مثلا قريه كانت امنه
مطمئنه
ياتيها ياتيها رزقها رغدا من كل مكان
فكفرت فكفرت بانعم الله فاذاقها الله لباس
الجو والخوف بما كانوا
يصنعون ولقد جاءهم رسول منهم
فكذبوه فاخذهم العذاب وهم
ظالمون فكلوا
مما رزقكم الله حلالا
طيبا واشكروا نعمه الله ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون
انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم
الخنزير وما اهل لغير الله
به فمن اطر غير باغ ولا عاد فلا اثم
عليه فان الله غفور رحيم ولا تقولوا لما
تصف السنتكم الكذبه هذا هذا حلال وهذا
حرام
لتفتروا لتفتروا على الله
الكذب ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا
يفلحون متاع قليل ولهم عذاب
اليم ومتاع قليل ولهم عذاب اليم
وعلى الذين هادوا حرمنا ما قصصنا عليك من
قبل وما ظلمناهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون ثم ان ربك للذين عملوا السوء
بجهاله ثم تابوا ثم تابوا من بعد ذلك
واصلحوا
ان ربك من بعدها غفور
رحيم ان ربك من بعد ذلك غفور
رحيم ان ابراهيم كان امه قانه لله
حنيفا حنيفا وما كان من
المشركين شاكرا لانعمه
ان ابراهيم كان
امه قانه لله حنيفا ولم يك من
المشركين شاكرا لانعمه اجتباه وهداه الى
صراط مستقيم
واتيناه في الدنيا حسنه
وانه في الاخره لمن
الصالحين ثم اوحينا اليك ان اتبع مله
ابراهيم
حنيفا وما كان من
المشركين انما جعل السبت على الذين
اختلفوا
فيه وان ربك ليحكم بينهم يوم القيامه فيما
كانوا فيه
يختلفون ادع الى سبيل لربك بالحكمه
والموعظه الحسنه
وجادلهم بالتي هي احسن
ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
بالمهتدين
وان عاقبتم فعاقبوا بمثل ما
عوقبتم به ولئن صبرتم لهو خير
للصابرين واصبر وما صبرك الا
بالله ولا تحزن عليهم ولا تك في
ضيق مما
يمكرون ان الله مع الذين
اتقوا ان الله مع الذي نقوا والذين
هم
محسنون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استقيم اعتدل
السو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
والعاديات ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به جمعا ان
الانسان لربه
لكنود
وانه على ذلك
لشهيد وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في القبور
وحصل ما في
الصدور ان
ربهم بهم يومئذ
لخبير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما تعبدون ولا انتم
عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده اللهم ولك الحمد
حمدا كث كثيرا طيبا مباركا فيه كما تحب
وترضاه مل السماء والارض ومل ما بينهما
ومل ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل الثناء والمجد
احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد اللهم اهدنا في منن هديت وعافنا فيمن
عافيت وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك ل نا فيما
اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قدرت وقضيت
انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل
من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك اللهم من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا
الذي هو عصمه امرنا واصلح لنا دنيانا التي
فيها معاشنا واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها
معادنا واجعل اللهم الحياه الدنيا زياده
لنا في كل خير والموت راحه لنا من كل شر
اللهم واجرنا من خزي الدن النيا وعذاب
الاخره اللهم انا نسالك من الخير كله
عاجله واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم
نعلم ونعوذ بك من الشر كله عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلمه اللهم
تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم اللهم
تقبل منا صلاتنا
وصيامنا
ودعائنا
وقيامنا وصالح
اعمالنا خالصه لوجهك الكريم كريم يا رب
العالمين اللهم ارحم والدينا ووالدين
والدينا اللهم ارحمنا وارحمهم وعافنا واعف
عنهم وعافنا واعف عنهم برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
وازواجنا
وذرياتنا
واخواننا ومن احبك فينا ومن احببناه فيك
اللهم اعتق رقابنا جميعا من
النار سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام
على المرسلين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله